mais que se passe-t-il avec tesla
début février le constructeur automobile
a connu des fluctuations de sa valeur
boursière assez inhabituel remontant le
fil de l'histoire
le 3 février dernier l'action qui était
en constante augmentation depuis fin
2010 9 fait un énorme bond en avant de
20% le 4 février un autre bond en avant
de 14%
tout ça grâce à des résultats meilleurs
que prévu au quatrième trimestre 2010 9
et des prévisions extrêmement optimiste
pour 2020 avec un objectif fixé de près
de 500 mille véhicules vendus en tout
l'action tesla a grimpé de plus de 110 %
depuis le début de l'année et de près de
400 % depuis juin dernier lui permettant
de devenir le deuxième constructeur
automobile mondial derrière toyota et
valant plus que general motors ford fiat
chrysler renault et psa réuni une bonne
nouvelle pour elon musk qui empochent
des bonus faramineux
dès que la valeur de tesla franchi
certains paliers sauf que le lendemain
le 5 février donc patatras l'action
plonge de 20% connaissant 1 6002 c'est
plus forte chute en passant de 887 à 724
$
la photo coronavirus qui a impacté la
production en chine
en obligeant tesla a fermé une de ses
usines ceci en tout cas d'une certaine
volatilité du titre tesla pas du tout
rassurant pour les marchés où certains
évoquent déjà nos statuts de bulles ou
de grenade en chocolat pour parler de
l'entreprise d'elon musk